our heart is broken Lisa we all love you
in the week of Lisa Marie Presley's
death a brewing Family Feud over dad
Elvis's massive estate and even bigger
Legacy it is huge you know to live under
the light of someone as big as Elvis
it's a big responsibility before her
death Lisa Marie seemingly appointed her
daughter from actress Riley Keough as
her sole trustee but Riley's grandmother
Priscilla Presley is fighting them
calling Lisa Marie's most recent Will
invalid speculating her signature was
forged previous versions marked
Priscilla as trustee and now a source
tells E.T this unexpected battle has
left Riley disappointed
she's so level-headed she's much further
advanced than I ever was
while no one in the family has commented
directly on the issue Priscilla did
release a statement to ET in the midst
of the increased tabloid attention on
her family's finances asking the public
to allow us the time we need to work
together and sort this out please ignore
the noise but the noise is getting
louder according to our Insider Riley
believes the challenge to Lisa Marie's
will goes against her mom's wishes and
it's pushing the family apart even more
all the children have to have their own
life obviously it's a struggle for them
because it's a huge name to carry the
source says Riley does want to have a
relationship with Priscilla but at this
point in time they are not close
leading up to Lisa Marie's death we're
told things between her and Priscilla
were quote very complicated in documents
from a 2018 lawsuit Lisa questioned why
her mother was making nine hundred
thousand dollars a year from Elvis
Enterprises despite having no stake in
the company childhood passes by with a
glimpse of her green eye
she then grew a family of her own
but any family infighting when
undetected at least some re-celebration
of Life Riley's husband took the stage
after Priscilla sharing this tribute on
his wife's behalf thank you for showing
me that love is the only thing that
matters in this life thank you for
giving me strength my heart my empathy
my Courage the one thing she said is
just don't make it sad she had many
thoughts about what her funeral would be
like there was no question she wanted to
be buried at Graceland amid the family
drama Joel weinshaker who oversees the
business dealings of Elvis's estate says
there's no question who Lisa Marie
wanted to look after the Presley Empire
Graceland included
although Riley is a movie star she's a
you know an award-winning director uh
she had always had an interest and
always known that one day uh she would
be in charge obviously it's much much
much sooner than we would ever hoped for
uh but on Lisa's birthday we just want
to think about you know what Lisa would
have wanted uh and that's what's best
for Elvis and you know she never had it
down her mind but that's Riley it's
absolutely 100 of mine always has been
mine Graceland always will be and when
it's no longer mine it would be my
children
foreign
[Music]